[Music]  we're continuing to follow that breaking  news happening right at the corner of  las vegas boulevard and sahara 8 news  now reporter madison kimbrough is at the  scene joining us now live with the very  latest madison  heavy police activity here on las vegas  boulevard as you can see at sahara  avenue all southbound lanes are blocked  we're still awaiting details from police  on what exactly happened but we can  confirm that three people have been shot  and the suspect is in custody so  obviously keep it here on eight news now  for the latest details it's a pretty  congested area here traffic is going  through northbound but as you can see  southbound lanes are closed at the  moment